Buonasera, mi spiace che siamo qua in condizioni insomma dal punto di vista climatico un po'
meno gradevoli del solito, d'altra parte mi dicono che qua dentro ci sta più gente che non sugli spalti
della fortezza e quindi va bene così alla fine. Voi sapete che l'idea di quest'anno per quanto
riguarda le mie tre lezioni è di presentare tre personaggi del medioevo, di presentare tre uomini
del medioevo provando a capire chi erano, come pensavano, come vedevano il mondo, un frate, un
mercante, un cavaliere. Naturalmente per poter sapere chi erano queste persone, per poter entrare
nella loro testa e com'è che si fa? Ebbè sono tre persone che hanno scritto, sono tre uomini che
hanno lasciato dietro di sé dei libri, delle cronache in cui hanno messo molto di se stessi.
Ovviamente questo, l'obiezione viene fuori subito, non erano proprio persone normali, un cavaliere che
ha scritto un libro non era proprio uguale a tutti gli altri cavalieri, un mercante che ha scritto
un libro peggio che mai, un frate ancora ancora, tutto sommato i frati scrivevano abbastanza, però
in ogni caso è chiaro che sono tre personaggi eccezionali e tuttavia ci hanno lasciato questi
tre personaggi delle opere talmente ampie che dentro c'è l'uomo, insomma ogni volta dentro c'è l'uomo,
c'è il suo modo di essere, il suo modo di ragionare, i suoi valori, i suoi pregiudizi,
il suo modo di vedere il mondo. Stasera cominciamo da un frate e io poi non ho fatto altro che dirmi
che ho fatto malissimo a cominciare dal frate perché dei tre il frate è quello che ha scritto
il libro più grosso. Io non me lo sono neanche portato stasera talmente grosso, nei prossimi giorni
me li porterò i libri del mercante e del cavaliere. Il libro del frate non l'ho portato perché il frate
di cui vi parlo ha scritto una cronaca che a stampa occupa circa 900 pagine e questo vuol dire
che non è stato per niente facile selezionare le cose da raccontarvi, scegliere nel mare di cose
che quest'uomo ci ha raccontato che cosa tirar fuori per provare a dare un'idea di chi era e di come
pensava. Comunque insomma ci provo. Questo frate si chiama Salimbene da Parma, si chiamerebbe Salimbene
de Adam, quella è la sua famiglia ma insomma lui appena è partito da Parma è stato conosciuto da tutti
come Salimbene da Parma. Questo Salimbene chi era dunque? È un frate francescano, è un frate del 200,
potrebbe essere il nonno di Dante come età più o meno. È un frate francescano e sotto molti aspetti
la sua mentalità, il suo modo di ragionare forse assomiglia a quello di tutti gli altri frati
ma sotto altri aspetti è un uomo con le sue idiosincrasie, con le sue caratteristiche personali.
Proviamo a vedere che cosa c'è nella testa di un frate del 200. Io direi che la prima cosa che colpisce
leggendo l'opera di Salimbene è la sua certezza di vivere in un mondo ordinato, in un mondo
razionale. Il mondo di Salimbene, il mondo di un italiano, di un frate italiano del 200 è un mondo
ordinato, razionale, non grazie agli uomini. Gli uomini sono dei cialtroni, dei delinquenti, fanno di
tutto per distruggere l'armonia della realtà, ma di per sé il mondo è ordinato perché Dio l'ha
costruito così. C'è questa profonda fiducia nel fatto che il mondo ha una sua logica, l'ha costruito
Dio e Dio ha dato anche all'uomo i mezzi per interpretarlo. Sono le Sacre Scritture, la Bibbia.
Le Sacre Scritture sono un gigantesco manuale di istruzioni per l'uso del mondo. Nella Bibbia,
agli occhi di uno come Salimbene, c'è tutto. Ci sono le risposte a tutte le domande. Qualunque
cosa succeda, uno che conosce la Bibbia trova nella Bibbia non uno, ma cinque, dieci, quindici
passi che gli parlano di quello che sta succedendo e gli indicano come comportarsi. La Bibbia è un
manuale labirintico pieno di contraddizioni, bisogna saperlo interpretare, però dentro c'è
tutto, permette di orientarsi nella vita. Se uno la conosce, è la prima cosa stupefacente che noi
troviamo se entriamo nella testa di Fra Salimbene, francescano padano del 200, è che lui la Bibbia
praticamente la sa a memoria. A dirlo oggi uno rischia di non crederci, perché eppure loro
funzionavano così, gli intellettuali di allora funzionavano così, avevano una capacità di
memorizzazione sbalorditiva rispetto a noi. La Bibbia la sa a memoria e del resto dovevano
saperla a memoria, perché Salimbene non è un frate qualunque, è un predicatore, è uno di quegli
uomini selezionati che sono stati scelti e preparati dalla Chiesa per parlare alla gente,
per stare su un podio in una sala con mille persone, parlare alla gente, farsi ascoltare e
farsi capire. Parlare alla gente di cosa? Lui doveva parlare di fede, di teologia, di religione,
doveva combattere gli eretici, doveva convincere la gente che la Chiesa ha ragione e gli eretici
hanno torto, per far questo doveva poter citare continuamente la Bibbia a sostegno di tutto quello
che diceva. E poi non basta, in quel mondo degli intellettuali di quell'epoca, come dire, era un
orgoglio saper bene le cose, essere bravi, essere in grado di affrontare una discussione, il loro
orgoglio stava nell'essere bravi nelle dispute pubbliche, ci sono tante cose da discutere, tante cose
incerte, diversi intellettuali si incontrano e in pubblico discutono e vince il più bravo e il più
bravo è anche quello che per sostenere le cose che dice sa citare la Bibbia, sa trovare 1, 5, 10 passi
della Bibbia che gli danno ragione e lì non ce l'ha il libro, lì devi saperla a memoria. Uno dice ma come
faceva sapere a memoria la Bibbia? Beh ma perché loro funzionavano così. C'è un passo in Salimbene
nella sua cronaca che è molto istruttivo. Salimbene a un certo punto cita una canzonetta satirica che
sfotte un domenicano, va sempre bene sfottere i domenicani per i francescani, ci ritorneremo, cita
una canzonetta satirica che prende in giro un domenicano, cita otto versi di questa canzonetta in
latino e poi dice Salimbene non me ne ricordo di più perché è passato tanto tempo da quando l'ho
letta e quando l'ho letta non me ne importava niente e quindi non l'ho imparata bene a memoria.
Questo capite cosa vuol dire? Vuol dire che uno normalmente quando legge impara a memoria e impara
a memoria per forza perché bisogna far così, perché i libri sono pochi, tanti dei libri che tu leggi li
leggi perché ti hanno mandato nel convento di Fano e nella biblioteca del convento di Fano c'è un bel
libro che ti interessa e tu lo leggi e chissà se lo ritroverai mai più quel libro, sono tutti scritti
a mano i libri e quindi tu lo leggi e lo impari a memoria. Di rado puoi permetterti di far copiare
un libro che ti interessa, te lo fai prestare, trovi un copista, hai i soldi, lo paghi oppure se ti
interessa davvero tanto ti ci metti tu, te lo copi. Un intellettuale di quell'epoca ogni tanto passa tre
mesi a copiarsi un libro che gli interessa molto e che gli hanno prestato. Quindi i libri hanno un
valore immenso, uno dice prendi appunti, non è mica facile. Su cosa? La carta l'hanno appena inventata e
costa cara, la pergamena costa ancora più cara. Salimben a un certo punto dice sì quando io ero
giovane avevo cominciato a scrivere una cronaca, non quella che ci è arrivata che lui ha poi scritto
quando era ormai vecchio, dice avevo cominciato a scrivere una cronaca, sono arrivato fino ai
Longobardi, poi ho dovuto smettere perché ero talmente povero che non potevo neanche procurarmi
la pergamena. Ecco in queste condizioni l'unico magazzino che uno ha a disposizione è la testa e
nella testa fa entrare tutto quello che può entrarci. Quindi uno come Salimben nella Bibbia la
sa a memoria. Sapere a memoria la Bibbia vuol dire sapersi orientare nel mondo, avere tutte le
risposte pronte. Hai alle angosce che puoi avere tu e hai i dubbi che ti pongono i fedeli. Perché i
frati sono importanti, perché i predicatori sono importanti, perché i fedeli sono pieni di dubbi,
ci deve essere qualcuno che sa rispondere ai loro dubbi. Salimben fa parte di quella schiera
ristretta di professionisti che sa rispondere ai dubbi dei fedeli. La Bibbia se uno la conosce bene
permette perfino di prevedere il futuro e questa è una cosa che a Salimben interessa tantissimo,
a lui come a tanti nel suo mondo, capite voi prevedere il futuro. Ecco loro sono abbastanza
convinti che si possa, perché nella Bibbia c'è già tutto, la Bibbia prefigura anche le cose che
devono ancora succedere e se uno ci lavora bene ha un manuale per prevedere anche il futuro. A
quell'epoca c'era una dottrina che andava per la maggiore, era la dottrina dell'abate Gioacchino
da Fiore. Questo era un monaco del secolo precedente, morto da un bel pezzo ormai, monaco
calabrese, il quale aveva costruito un immenso sistema di interpretazione della Bibbia che doveva
permettere di prevedere il futuro. La Chiesa ufficialmente non ha mai detto sì è vero, non
ha neanche mai detto sono tutte stupidaggini, lasciava che ognuno si facesse la sua idea. Molti
erano i Gioacchimiti, come si diceva, cioè quelli che credevano a questo sistema e Salimbene
che scrive da vecchio dice io ora non ci credo più perché ho toccato con mano che le previsioni
non sono tornate, non funzionano, però ci credevo, ci ho creduto a lungo. Salimbene è nato intorno
a 1220-30, l'abate Gioacchino tanto tempo prima aveva previsto che nel 1260 il mondo sarebbe
cambiato, non chiedetemi che calcoli aveva fatto sulla cronologia della Bibbia ma erano calcoli
imponenti. Nel 1200 cosa doveva succedere? Doveva succedere che al mondo arriva l'anticristo
e questo si sa che succederà perché lo dice l'apocalisse, quindi è già scritto, quel
pezzo del futuro è già scritto, si sa, arriverà l'anticristo, commetterà i peggiori crimini,
il mondo sprofonderà nel sangue, poi però diceva l'abate Gioacchino nel 1260 l'anticristo
sarà sconfitto e il mondo entrerà in una nuova era di grazia, di felicità, di armonia.
Salimbene da giovane ci ha creduto e quelli come lui che ci credevano qual era il loro
problema principale secondo voi? Stiamo a vedere chi è l'anticristo, dovrà comparire
prima o poi, appena compare cerchiamo di indovinarlo che è lui. A un certo punto si delinea un candidato
che sembra sicuro, l'imperatore Federico II, Federico II di Svevia, stupor mundi, grande
nemico del papato, grande uomo di potere e di cultura del 200, amatissimo da alcuni,
temutissimo da altri, uomo fuori dal mondo, veramente ne riparleremo alla fine. Ecco, per
molti Federico II è lui l'anticristo, sta già commettendo dei delitti, peggiorerà ancora,
Salimbene ci ha creduto. Molti anni dopo dice, a un certo punto si è sparsa la notizia che
l'imperatore Federico II era morto e io non ci volevo credere perché ero talmente convinto che
era lui l'anticristo e però non si era ancora manifestato in pieno tutto il disastro che
l'anticristo doveva provocare, quindi io non ci credevo. Poi ci ho dovuto credere, dice Salimbene,
perché l'ho sentito dalla bocca del papa. Stavo a Ferrara, è passato di lì il papa, ha predicato
alla gente, io ero lì sul balcone accanto a lui, lo toccavo e il papa ha annunciato pubblicamente
che l'imperatore Federico II era morto, dice 1250, dice Salimbene 30 anni dopo, ci sono rimasto
malissimo perché vedevo crollare tutto il sistema che io mi ero immaginato di previsione
del futuro. E tanti ci credono a questa cosa che si possa prevedere il futuro. Salimbene
non è più Gioachimita, non crede più al sistema di Gioachino, ma è pronto a credere ad altre
cose perché veramente a loro li appassiona questa idea. Noi beninteso crediamo di sapere
già adesso quanto sarà la crescita del PIL del 2012 e questo è altrettanto ridicolo
evidentemente, anzi probabilmente di più. Loro ci tenevano a immaginare il futuro. A Salimbene
a un certo punto vengono a raccontare che c'è un tizio, un profeta, ecco è comparso
un nuovo profeta, chi è? Un poveraccio, un poveraccio di Parma, la sua città, Salimbene
di Parma, un tessitore. Questo a un certo punto ha cominciato a profetizzare e le cose che
diceva funzionava insomma. A un certo punto si è ritirato in un monastero, un monastero
dei cistercensi, Fonte Vivo, fuori Parma. I cistercensi l'hanno accolto e dice Salimbene
ma han parlato tanto di quest'uomo che sta lì in questo monastero, sta tutto il giorno
chiuso in camera a scrivere, un artigiano capite, un operaio, un tessitore e profetizza
il futuro. Salimbene gli sente raccontare queste cose e poi viene il momento che insomma
non sta più nella pelle, vuole andarlo a conoscere questo. Parte, va al monastero di
Fonte Vivo, arriva lì, ci trova un suo amico, un francescano, un altro francescano, che è
medico, quindi fa il medico, sta lì dai cistercensi che sono un altro ordine, che lo tengono
lì perché gli serve un medico. Quest'altro francescano che vive lì gli dice
a Salimbene guarda io ti potrei prestare tutti i libri che vuoi ma quest'uomo che cerchi
è morto. E dice Salimbene ma avrà lasciato i suoi libri, io so che scriveva continuamente,
anzi so, dimenticavo di dirvelo, Salimbene prima ha raccontato quest'uomo scrive, scrive
e dice testualmente Salimbene pubblica volentieri le sue opere. Questa è un'altra cosa straordinaria
perché noi oggi che scriviamo libri per noi pubblicare vuol dire andare ad un editore
e farlo stampare. Cosa fai stampare un libro nel 200 che non c'è la stampa? Eppure loro
hanno questa idea pubblicare vuol dire uno scrive? Beh scrive per se stesso, scrive per
la famiglia semmai, i libri di ricordi, poi invece c'è chi scrive e ha piacere che le
sue cose siano conosciute e quindi le fa circolare, se uno viene lì gliele fa leggere, gliele fa
copiare perché bisogna copiare tutto a mano. Questo profeta pubblicava volentieri le sue opere
e quindi Salimbene arriva al monastero e dice ma saranno rimasti i suoi libri e l'amico
gli dice non è rimasto niente dei suoi libri, come mai? E l'amico un francescano anche lui
gli dice ma sai questo qua molti ci credevano ma secondo me c'erano dei grossi problemi in
questa idea delle sue profezie, insomma te la faccio breve gli dice l'amico. Qui nel monastero
c'è un vecchio monaco che lavora nel nostro scriptorium, nell'officina dove si copiano i
manoscritti e che ha una sua arte particolare, è un tecnico di una cosa specifica, è un tecnico
della cancellatura dei manoscritti. Perché la cancellatura dei manoscritti? Voi capite
siamo sempre allo stesso problema, la pergamena costa cara e non si trova sempre. È una biblioteca
dove si producono dei libri può trovarsi spesso nella situazione che bisogna fare un
libro nuovo, c'è un'occasione di copiare un libro importante e non c'è pergamena, allora
cosa si fa? Beh si cancella un manoscritto vecchio che non serve più, è un'arte, ci deve
essere uno che sa grattar via la scrittura senza rovinare la pergamena. Noi oggi ci mettiamo
le mani nei capelli pensiamo chissà quanta roba è andata perduta ma per loro era indispensabile
e dunque continua l'amico di Salimbene, c'era questo vecchio monaco che conosceva quell'arte
e dice io prima o poi morirò, vorrei trasmetterla a qualcuno questa tecnica e io dice l'amico
non c'era nessuno che voleva mettersi a imparare questa cosa, mi sono messo io, ho imparato la
tecnica della rasatura dei manoscritti e siccome avevo bisogno di manoscritti per esercitarmi e ho
pensato che i libri di questo profeta era meglio che non circolassero troppo, li ho cancellati
tutti. Salimbene ci rimane malissimo anche questa volta e però dice, notate che è interessante
questa mentalità perché è già la mentalità che molto tempo dopo porterà l'inquisizione a fare i
roghi di libri e la chiesa a pubblicare l'indice dei libri proibiti, però la cosa interessante è che
all'epoca di Salimbene non è ancora il potere della chiesa che impone questo, c'è ancora molta
libertà, le idee girano, i libri circolano, però ognuno, ognuno di quelli che fanno parte
dell'apparato della chiesa voglio dire, dei dotti, di quelli che hanno il compito di guidare i fedeli
alla salvezza, ognuno ha la responsabilità individuale di decidere se i libri sono buoni o
non sono buoni e se non sono buoni si assume la responsabilità individuale di impedire che circolino.
dunque Salimbene appartiene a un gruppo sociale coltissimo, non è solo la bibbia che sa memoria,
lui ha una biblioteca nella testa, appartiene a un gruppo sociale che guida il mondo non dal
punto di vista politico ma dal punto di vista morale, spirituale, la cultura e la loro identità,
questa è gente che scrive, parla e pensa in latino, pensa anche nel suo dialetto, Salimbene
pensa nel suo dialetto di Parma, si vede benissimo dal latino che scrive, però sa anche pensare,
parlare e scrivere in latino e questa capacità che ti distingue dalla gente qualunque è un
elemento importante dell'identità di questi frati. È talmente importante che anche il loro
nemico principale, il diavolo, condivide questo orgoglio di saper parlare bene il latino e di essere
colto, c'è una storia che racconta Salimbene che da questo punto di vista è esemplare. C'era un
frate, dice che conosco, a un certo punto gli hanno portato un indemoniato, gli hanno portato un
indemoniato, un contadino, un villano, un uomo rozzo, posseduto dal diavolo. Il frate gli si mette
davanti, dice beh però bisogna controllare perché non è mica sempre che sia così, bisogna vedere se
davvero questo è posseduto dal diavolo. E il frate dice, diavolo se sei lì dentro dimostramelo,
parlami in latino. E il diavolo per bocca del contadino comincia a parlare in latino e fa degli
errori di grammatica. E il frate comincia a prenderlo in giro dicendo fammi ridere, tu sapresti
parlare latino, ma senti che latino parli, non vale niente. E il diavolo che condivide perfettamente
il sistema di valori dei frati si arrabbia e gli dice testualmente io so parlare latino bene
quanto te, è solo che con la bocca di questo contadino come si fa? Ha una lingua talmente
rozza che non ci riesco a parlare bene con la sua bocca. Ovviamente questo ideale diciamo di un'elite
dotta, di un'elite culturale, orgogliosa della sua cultura è anche un rischio. L'orgoglio della cultura
diventa facilmente presunzione. Salimbene lo sa, ci casca anche lui spesso. Non si contano i momenti
in cui lui dice io la Bibbia la conosco, non mi possono mica fregare. Questo orgoglio è un rischio,
lui se ne rende conto, racconta anche varie storie che mostrano come insomma un grande predicatore
deve stare attento perché il rischio della presunzione è sempre lì pronto. Ci sono un paio
di aneddoti che lui racconta su un grande predicatore del suo tempo fra Giovanni da Vicenza
il quale è un domenicano, quindi sui domenicani appunto viene, si raccontano volentieri storie
insomma che non li mettono tanto in buona luce. Fra Giovanni da Vicenza è un grande predicatore,
è uno di questi uomini che sanno stare su un palco o su un balcone e parlare a una piazza piena
di gente, far piangere la gente quando vogliono a comando, ecco gente così si inorgoglisce un po'
di essere così brava. Fra Giovanni da Vicenza a un certo punto si era convinto di essere santo
e fin lì passi, si era convinto di saper fare i miracoli da solo senza neanche bisogno che Dio
intervenisse e soprattutto voleva che gli altri lo ammirassero come un santo. Dice Salimbene un giorno
fra Giovanni da Vicenza è capitato in uno dei nostri conventi francescani, già che c'era ne ha
approfittato per farsi radere la barba dal barbiere del convento e poi si è offeso perché i frati non
raccoglievano i peli della sua barba come reliquie. I francescani dopo un po' di questo fra Giovanni
da Vicenza non ne possono più e Salimbene racconta con grandissimo godimento quello che è successo
dopo. Dice c'era uno dei nostri frati un fiorentino dice Salimbene frate Dio ti salvi da Firenze e
Salimbene dice questo è molto interessante si sa che ai fiorentini piace sfottere piace beffare che
sono dei gran burloni ecco siamo 50 anni prima di Boccaccio ma è già uno stereotipo i fiorentini
sono così a loro piace fare scherzi anche cattivi allora dice Salimbene con grande divertimento e
approvazione il nostro frate dieti salvi è andato al convento domenicano dove c'era fra Giovanni l'hanno
invitato a pranzo lui dice sì sì va bene resto a pranzo però voi qui avete il santo voi qui avete
il santo io non posso andare via senza una sua reliquia se volete che resti a pranzo datemi una
reliquia del santo un pezzo della sua tunica un brandello della sua tunica e i domenicani contentissimi
che il loro santo sia così ammirato vanno prendono una vecchia tunica ritagliano un pezzo
e gli danno un pezzo della tunica dopodiché racconta Salimbene ripeto con grande divertimento
ed entusiasmo mangiano dopo avere ben mangiato frate dieti salvi va a espletare le sue funzioni
corporali va alle latrine voi mi scuserete ma come dire questa gente del medioevo sapeva
coniugare un'altezza intellettuale a volte vertiginosa con un grande interesse per la
corporalità per il basso per le cose più ignobili anzi per loro era importante l'equilibrio fra queste
due cose pensate a Dante ecco e qui è la stessa cosa quindi Salimbene racconta e io racconto
il frate dieti salvi va alla latrina e naturalmente poi si pulisce con il pezzo di tonica del santo
che gli hanno appena dato e poi la lascia cadere e si mette a gridare ai aiuto aiuto ho perso la
reliquia venite aiutarmi a tirarla fuori e arrivano tutti i domenicani di corsa a cercare di tirarla
fuori e lui rimesta nella latrina con un bastone per tirarla fuori finché dopo un po' i domenicani
mangiano la foglia capiscono quello che sta succedendo e se ne vanno tutti scornati e Salimbene
di fronte a queste storie è entusiasta ora cosa vuol dire vuol dire appunto stiamo attenti perché
la nostra cultura si trasforma facilmente in presunzione vuol dire stiamo attenti perché noi
viviamo nella sfera dello spirito della cultura ma ci sono anche il corpo la materialità e quelle cose
esistono e contano non si possono ignorare e vuole anche dire i domenicani comunque sono un po' peggio
di noi francescani e questo è indiscutibile l'altra grande certezza che c'è nella testa di Salimbene
è che i francescani sono l'organizzazione più meravigliosa che esista al mondo sono loro che fanno
tutto il lavoro la chiesa vive su di loro essere un francescano è la cosa più importante che si può
immaginare non c'è nessun altro che arrivi alla stessa altezza tanto che il metro di giudizio di
Salimbene per giudicare le persone spesso è quello lì un vescovo un papa ha voluto bene i francescani
quelli che hanno voluto bene i francescani li han trattati bene gli si perdona tutto perché i
francescani sono comunque il meglio che ci sia e quindi la concorrenza invece è la concorrenza
ovviamente da fastidio i domenicani ancora ancora adesso ho scherzato sui domenicani ma sono un
grande ordine fratello sono i mendicanti anche loro ma ce n'è ben altra di concorrenza perché
all'epoca di Salimbene l'idea di san francesco di creare un movimento di gente che rinuncia alla
ricchezza che va in giro coi sandali o scalza di gente che pratica la povertà degli apostoli che
imita cristo questa idea la stanno imitando in tanti e l'altra cosa che c'è ben ferma nella
testa di Salimbene è che attenzione perché noi francescani abbiamo un esempio preciso san
francesco ci ha insegnato come si fa questa cosa ma non è che il primo venuto adesso si mette un
paio di sandali e pretende di fare come noi questa è una vergogna è una cosa scandalosa quando
Salimbene pensa queste cose perde il lume dell'intelletto e scrive pagine e pagine per deplorare
questa concorrenza sleale c'è un movimento in particolare che lui conosce bene perché è nato
a parma è un movimento che si chiama il movimento degli apostolici l'ha fondato uno che si chiama frate
gerardino segalelli questo dice Salimbene è uno che voleva diventare francescano ma era un cialtrone e
non l'hanno voluto e allora lui si è fatto il suo movimento si è creato il suo ordine nel nostro
convento aveva visto un'immagine degli apostoli dice Salimbene sapete tutti come li rappresentiamo
con i sandali il mantello avvolto intorno alle spalle lui ha visto quello ha creduto di dover fare
la stessa cosa e quindi ha creato questo movimento che sono dei buffoni degli analfabeti dei porcai
dei guardiani di pecore che si sono messi in testa di fare come noi francescani in realtà non sanno
niente sono analfabeti non servono a nulla non dicono messa non pregano per i loro benefattori non
danno buoni consigli non sanno disputare non conoscono la bibbia sono completamente inutili
stanno tutto il giorno in piazza a guardare le donne
eppure dice Salimbene la gente dà più elemosina a loro che a noi
è il mondo alla rovescia e questo Gerardino Segalelli appunto vi cito una cosa di lui perché qualcuno di voi
la riconoscerà dice Salimbene Gerardino Segalelli era talmente analfabeta che quando andava in giro
voleva lanciare un'esortazione uno slogan alla gente che lo ascoltava voleva dire fate penitenza
penitenziam agite ma siccome il latino lo masticava male borbottava una cosa e veniva fuori
penitenzi agite ecco qualcuno si ricorderà che Umberto Eco ha ripreso testualmente questo brano di Salimbene
nel nome della rosa e poi anche nel film è lo slogan che racconta che è sempre in bocca a Salvatore
e al suo movimento di perseguitati ecco Eco ha attinto a piene mani a Salimbene per il nome della rosa
e dunque e dunque Salimbene io sono sicuro che tutte le cose che ho detto di lui finora non lo so
ecco non sono sicuro ma non so quanto lo rendono simpatico certamente diciamo è un arrogante
intellettuale sicuro di appartenere a un'elite di padroni del mondo che hanno le risposte a tutto
e che devono predicare parlare farsi ascoltare
c'è da dire che Salimbene per diventare francescano ha fatto delle rinunce che credo pochi sarebbero stati disposti a fare
perché Salimbene di nascita era un gran signore
Salimbene era un aristocratico di una grande famiglia di cavalieri di Parma
quando noi pensiamo ai comuni italiani non dobbiamo immaginarci soltanto questi comuni italiani
pieni di laboriosi mercanti e di artigiani intenti a far soldi non è così
nei comuni italiani del medioevo i mercanti e gli artigiani e i soldi c'erano e come
ne parleremo anche domani ma accanto a loro c'erano i nobili i nobili cavalieri
gente grandi famiglie aristocratiche fiere del loro sangue dei loro cavalli delle loro armi
gente che sapeva fare la guerra quelli che costruivano le torri nelle nostre città medievali
uomini abituati a farsi giustizia da soli a vendicarsi con la violenza dei torti subiti
Salimbene nasce in quell'ambiente
a proposito della vendetta a un certo punto a Salimbene scappa questa cosa dice
a Parma una vendetta vecchia di 30 anni non è considerata fuori tempo
e anch'io sono di Parma dice Salimbene
ora Salimbene è di una grande famiglia nobile
e suo padre il cavaliere Messer Guido de Adam quando ha saputo che suo figlio si era fatto francescano ha dato di matto
perché il nobile cavaliere aveva due figli uno il maggiore si era già fatto francescano
c'è il secondo va bene rimane il secondo anche al secondo Salimbene viene in mente di farsi francescano
per un nobile è una tragedia rimani senza figli rimani senza nessuno che raccolga la tua eredità
voi dovete pensare che per i nobili dell'epoca la famiglia la stirpa il lignaggio il sangue la discendenza
ecco lasciare qualcuno che subentri a me col mio cognome la mia insegna
questa è una cosa fondamentale nella mentalità aristocratica
e Salimbene che era l'erede di un nobile cavaliere ha deciso a 17 anni di mollare tutto e andare coi frati
questa è una cosa che non capiremo mai abbastanza quanto è stata grossa e quanto è stata pesante
e infatti è stata pesante perché la famiglia ha cercato di impedirglielo
quando Salimbene scappa di casa e va con i francescani
certo i francescani sono già un grande ordine importante, influente
però è pur sempre gente che va in giro scalza a mendicare di porta in porta
agli occhi di un cavaliere è una vita vergognosa e per di più il mio unico figlio
Messer Guido de Adam si muove e siccome appartiene all'alta aristocrazia si muove da par suo
si rivolge direttamente all'imperatore Federico II
e gli dice guarda che mio figlio è scappato coi frati fammelo restituire
questo è il livello a cui si muove la famiglia di Salimbene
e l'imperatore Federico scrive al generale dei francescani frate Elia
dicendogli così e così mi risulta tu vedi
questo ragazzo cerchiamo di restituirlo al padre
a meno che non voglia a tutti i costi restare lì
e con questa lettera Messer Guido de Adam va al convento dove si trova Salimbene
è finito nel convento di Fano in Romagna
il padre arriva lì brandendo la lettera dell'imperatore e del generale dell'ordine
accompagnato da parecchi cavalieri fa irruzione nel convento
e dice ai frati voglio parlare con mio figlio
e gli portano il figlio
e il padre gli dice ma tu sei il mio erede erediti tutto
cosa stai qua torna a casa
e Salimbene che racconta questa storia 50 anni dopo quando ormai è vecchio
Salimbene racconta orgoglioso di aver tenuto duro
al padre ha detto
nel Vangelo sta scritto lasciate il padre e la madre per seguire me
e io faccio così
più altre citazioni bibliche assortite che vi risparmio
voi immaginate un diciassettenne è l'età in cui col padre si litiga furiosamente anche adesso
e si litigava furiosamente anche allora come in ogni epoca quelle tali
Salimbene al padre dice le cose peggiori
dice no non voglio venire
e il padre gli dice
sono questi qua che te l'hanno messo in testa
i frati
voglio parlare con lui da solo
e i frati sono costretti a accettare
escono tutti
ma dice Salimbene
stavano dall'altra parte del muro ad ascoltare
e il padre rimane solo con Salimbene
e il padre dice al figlio diciassettenne testualmente
figlio mio
non credere a questi piscia in tonaca
che ti hanno incantato
Salimbene che scrive in latino
glossa in latino
non credere istis pissin tunicis
id est qui in tunicis
mingunt
cioè che orino
spiega
t'hanno incantato
t'hanno messo in testa queste cose
torna a casa Salimbene tiene duro
e dice i frati dall'altra parte erano lì che tremavano come giunchi
temendo che io cedessi perché se cedevo io
chissà chi altri avrebbe accettato di venire in convento
invece io ho tenuto duro
tiene duro e il padre se ne va
maledicendolo
maledice lui e l'altro figlio
li raccomanda al diavolo
non lo vedrà mai più il padre
Salimbene 50 anni dopo
racconta questa cosa
detto 50?
sì
50 anni dopo
racconta questa cosa
orgoglioso
dopodiché dice anche
sono stato premiato
quella notte stessa per fortuna
ho avuto un sogno
che mi ha fatto capire
che avevo fatto bene
perché evidentemente
è come dire
il trauma
anche se lui adesso è così orgoglioso
di averlo fatto
il trauma c'era
di questa rottura
totale col padre
che lo maledice
lo manda all'inferno
e per fortuna
quella notte
racconta Salimbene
mi è apparsa in sogno
la vergine
col bambino in braccio
e mi tendevano le braccia
perché venissi a abbracciarli
e io in sogno
andavo ad abbracciarli
e provavo una dolcezza
come non ho mai più provato
in vita mia
e poi mi sono svegliato
e avevo ancora dentro
quella dolcezza
che non saprei
voi sapete quando si fanno
certi sogni
che ti lasciano dentro
ecco
queste storie qua
si capisce
come dire
a raccontarle al dottor Freud
ci sarebbe da tirarne fuori
di commenti
Salimbene
non conosceva il dottor Freud
però
come dire
per lui
e quindi
era davvero
la vergine
col bambino
che gli era apparsa
perché aveva visto tutto
e voleva dirgli
che aveva fatto bene
e che lei era con lui
a ricompensarlo
per questo
il padre poi ci riprova
ci riprova ancora
va dal papa
sono perfino
mezzi parenti
col papa
talmente importante
la famiglia
e Salimbene
in seguito
gliel'hanno detto
guarda che tuo padre
era andato anche dal papa
per convincerlo
a tirarti fuori
dall'ordine francescano
e qui Salimbene
dice una cosa caratteristica
dice
io
non credo
che il papa
avrebbe accettato
ma
forse
per far piacere
a mio padre
mi avrebbe dato
un episcopato
cioè mi avrebbe
fatto vescovo
e si vede
che questa cosa qui
un pochettino
gli rimane
poteva anche succedere
che diventavo vescovo
e invece non è successo
e pazienza
dopodiché
non finisce qui
il trauma
dell'essere entrato
nell'ordine francescano
io credo che sia importante
dire questo
siccome
noi vediamo Salimbene
frate importante
uomo che ha contatto
con papi e vescovi
uomo che conta
uomo di potere
è importante ricordare
che quest'uomo di potere
va scalzo
e va in giro
a mendicare
per vivere
e che questa cosa
lui l'ha vissuta
come un trauma
pesantissimo
a un certo punto
l'hanno mandato
a mendicare
a fare la questua
e lui si vergognava
come un ladro
a andare di porta
in porta
a fare la questua
era a Pisa
in quel momento
era nel convento
di Pisa
faceva la questua
e lui racconta
mi trovavo
in quella certa strada
stavo da un lato
da un certo lato
della strada
perché dall'altra parte
c'era il fondaco
dei mercanti di Parma
e io volevo evitare
di incontrare
qualcuno di Parma
perché mi vergognavo
troppo con la gente
che conoscevo
dunque faceva la questua
a Pisa
e a un certo punto
ha la sfortuna
che incontra davvero
uno di Parma
lo stesso
dice mi viene incontro
uno che era di Parma
che io non conoscevo
ma lui mi conosceva
perché salì in bene
di una famiglia importante
e questo lo prende
per il saio
e comincia a dirgli
ma disgraziato
ma cosa ci fai qui
ma guardati come
ti sei ridotto
a casa di tuo padre
è pieno di servi
che hanno da mangiare
a sazietà
e tu stai qua
a mendicare
a portare via
il pane
a quelli più poveri
di te
e poi continua
e dice
salì in bene
riferisce parola per parola
dice tu a quest'ora
dovresti essere a Parma
a andare in giro
a cavallo
a farti vedere
nei tornei
a far felice
la gente che assiste
ai tornei
perché i nobili cavalieri
cosa fanno
è quello
a farti ammirare
dalle dame
e a dar mance
ai giullari
questo dovresti fare
tu adesso
non stare qui scalzo
a battere alle porte
a mendicare
e salì in bene
quella volta
lo respinge
lo caccia via
in malo modo
gli cita un po'
di passi biblici
però poi dice
quella sera al convento
mi sono messo a pensarci
mi sono detto
ma certo che se poi
mi tocca andare avanti
altri 50 anni così
a mendicare
dice quella volta lì
se l'è chiesto davvero
se non aveva sbagliato
tutto nella vita
per fortuna
anche quella notte
gli arriva un sogno
sogna
che è a Pisa
a mendicare
e a un certo punto
lì un po' più in là
nella stessa strada
c'è Gesù Bambino
che va anche lui
con la sporta a mendicare
e la Vergine
che va anche lei
con la sporta a mendicare
e allora
capisce che dopo tutto
sta facendo la cosa giusta
e questi sogni
arrivano sempre
appunto ripeto
il dottor Freud
ci potrebbe assistere
questi sogni arrivano sempre
al momento giusto
ultima rinuncia
che non possiamo
non menzionare
gravissima
dice Salimbene
la prima sera
che sono entrato
dai Francescani
mi è andata
una magnifica cena
a partire dal giorno dopo
solo cavoli
ho mangiato cavoli
tutti i giorni
della mia vita
e dice Salimbene
signorino di buona famiglia
ben allevato
e io prima
a me prima
i cavoli
facevano talmente schifo
che non mangiavo
neanche la carne
se era stata cotta
con i cavoli
e da allora invece
cavoli tutti i giorni
bene
Salimbene
dunque appunto
figlio di una grande
famiglia nobile
ha fatto una scelta
che l'ha portato
molto lontano
dalla sua famiglia
tuttavia
di questa nascita
ha conservato
alcune caratteristiche
proprio di modo
di pensare
di sistema di valori
e io direi
che la cosa che colpisce
di più leggendo Salimbene
è che lui è rimasto
un nobile cavaliere
da un punto di vista
che per lui
la vera misura
degli uomini
sono la cortesia
o la villania
gli uomini
che a lui piacciono
sono quelli
cortesi
cavallereschi
generosi
beneducati
mentre quelli
maleducati
rozzi
avari
villani
ecco quelli
non li può proprio
sopportare
e questi sono i valori
dell'ambiente cavalleresco
del mondo cortese
in cui lui è nato
sono quelli i valori
in base a cui giudica
gli uomini
non il fatto
che siano dei peccatori
o no
perché tutti
sono dei peccatori
figuriamoci
Salimbene ne ha viste
di tutti i colori
non si fa nessuna illusione
la gente
gli uomini
sono quello che sono
anche il clero
è quello che è
Salimbene davvero
non si fa nessuna illusione
lui ha visto
in vita sua di tutto
ha visto perfino
un vescovo ateo
ha visto il vescovo
di Parma
che in punto di morte
quando gli portavano
i sacramenti
ha detto
ma no io non li voglio
tanto non ci credo
e quando gli hanno chiesto
ma allora perché
hai fatto il vescovo
ha risposto
beh
per le ricchezze
e per gli onori
quindi Salimbene
ha visto tutto
ha sentito raccontare
di tutto
su papi
arcivescovi
podestà
imperatori
principi
re
lui ha un intercalare
preferito
quando racconta qualcosa
di veramente enorme
che gli è stato riferito
di qualche personaggio
importante
lui dice
ipse viderit
se la vedrà lui
perché poi ognuno
se la vedrà individualmente
al momento buono
quando comparirà davanti
al suo creatore
e quindi ognuno
se la vedrà
anche se è il papa
noi non dobbiamo
rispettare nessuno
se non c'è motivo
e questo crea
una libertà
di giudizio
che è importante
appunto
nell'atteggiamento
di Salimbene
se un potente
è pieno di vizi
però è generoso
liberale
cortese
beh può andar bene
tutto sommato
l'arcivescovo di Ravenna
Filippo
aveva due nipoti
ma uno era suo figlio
e questo figlio
e anche l'altro
nipote
eh
prendevano tangenti
se uno gli faceva
dei regali
poi dall'arcivescovo
otteneva tutto
quello che voleva
appalti
concessioni
e tuttavia
aveva anche una figlia
che ha messo in convento
ma
tuttavia
l'arcivescovo di Ravenna
era un gran signore
ospitale
generoso
trattava bene la gente
Salimbene l'ha conosciuto
lui l'ha sempre trattato bene
lo invitava a pranzo
dava dai grandi pranzi
dava da mangiare a tutti
beveva del buon vino
ne dava a tutti
quando diceva
l'ufficio nel suo palazzo
andava avanti e indietro
nella stanza
l'arcivescovo di Ravenna
e ogni angolo
della stanza
aveva una caraffina
di vino
in fresco
dentro dell'acqua gelida
e quando arrivava all'angolo
si rinfrescava un po'
e poi ricominciava a dire
l'ufficio divino
ma invitava
era cortese
e beneducato
non come frate Elia
il generale
dell'ordine francescano
che un giorno
quando un gran signore
è andato a trovarlo
frate Elia
l'ha ricevuto
seduto a tavola
su un divano
pieno di
imbottito di cuscini
con un bel fuoco acceso
il berretto in testa
e frate Elia
generale dei francescani
all'ingresso
di un ospite importante
non si è neanche alzato
per riceverlo
questa dice
Salimbene
ecco
tutti hanno detto
uno così
ecco
non ci sono parole
non si può essere così
la maleducazione
la villania
e l'avarizia
sono le peggiori cose
che si possano immaginare
io dovrò tagliare
signori miei
perché qui si fa tardi
ve l'ho detto
che sono 900 pagine
vero
la cronaca di Salimbene
ci sono alcune cose
che voglio raccontare
per forza
e quindi
scorcerò
qua e là
vorrei fermarmi
un pochino
su questo fatto
del cibo
del mangiare
perché è di nuovo
importante
insomma il mio impegno
è anche di provare
a farvi capire
cosa hanno in testa
queste persone
ecco il mangiare
e il vino
sono cose importanti
questo è un mondo
ancora semplice
dal punto di vista
materiale
è un mondo
ancora povero
dove il ricco
è ancora quello
che mangia
in abbondanza
e dunque
le persone si giudicano
anche da quelle
queste cose
sono importanti
sono importantissime
qual è
un comportamento
che Salimbene
giudica fantastico
gli hanno raccontato
che il re d'Inghilterra
un giorno
era fare un picnic
picnic lo diciamo noi
ma insomma
era in campagna
si era messo a mangiare
su un prato
con i suoi cavalieri
portano il vino
sono vicino a una fontana
di vino
c'è soltanto un fiasco
e il re dice
ma scusate
ma c'è solo questo fiasco di vino
dice sì
non ce n'è altro
ci sono tutti i suoi cavalieri
intorno
e allora il re dice
berremo tutti insieme
e verse il fiasco di vino
nella fonte
dicendo
ognuno può bere lì
il vino e l'acqua mescolati
questa cosa
per Salimbene
è un gesto fantastico
perché vuol dire
un uomo
veramente cortese
veramente ben educato
che si mette
al livello degli altri
non come fanno
certi vescovi
dice Salimbene
i quali se ne stanno a casa
a bere e mangiare
non invitano nessuno
e se hanno gente
a banchetto con loro
il vino migliore
lo beve solo il vescovo
e agli altri
danno quello cattivo
oppure il vescovo beve
e gli altri niente
quando dice Salimbene
berrebbero tutti volentieri
perché tutte le gole
sono sorelle
sul vino
potremmo continuare
perché il vino
è un tema importante
appunto
a Salimbene
a un certo punto
raccontano
che in Borgogna
si fa più vino
che a Cremona
Parma
Reggio
e Modena
messe insieme
lui dice
non ci ho mica creduto
mi sembrava impossibile
poi ha fatto
un lungo viaggio
in Francia
che racconteremo adesso
finiremo con quello
ha fatto un lungo viaggio
in Francia
è stato in Borgogna
e ha visto
dice
è una cosa da non credere
l'intero paese
è un unico vigneto
lì non ci sono campi
non coltivano il grano
niente
fanno solo vino
lo vendono a Parigi
vivono benissimo di quello
e il vino di Borgogna
sul vino di Borgogna
ci sono pagine
in Salimbene
liriche
il vino bianco
di Borgogna
perché a quell'epoca
i nobili bevono volentieri
il vino bianco
il rosso è una roba
da cafoni
ma il bianco
è il bianco di Borgogna
dorato
profumato
certo poi
dice Salimbene
i francesi esagerano
perché i francesi
sono degli sbevazzoni
bevono
bevono troppo
quando hanno bevuto
credono di poter
spaccare il mondo
sono insopportabili
dice a dire la verità
bevono
poi si svegliano al mattino
con gli occhi rossi
ci sposi
per tutto il vino
che hanno bevuto
vanno alla prima messa
vanno dal sacerdote
e gli dicono
gli chiedono un po'
dell'acqua
in cui lui ha fatto
le abluzioni rituali
che gliela metta negli occhi
per piacere
perché pensano
che con quell'acqua
consacrata
gli guariscono
gli occhi rossi
per il troppo bere
e io dice salimbene
una volta
quando ero in francia
ho conosciuto
un frate
che quando uno
è venuto
a chiedergli
l'acqua
da mettere
negli occhi
gli ha detto
ma va via
mettete l'acqua
nel vino
non negli occhi
dopo di che
sapete come sono
organizzati i francescani
in francia
salimbene lo sa
e ce lo dice
dice la provincia
di francia
dell'ordine francescano
è divisa in otto
custodie
in otto settori
di cui
quattro bevono vino
e quattro bevono birra
questa è
la spartizione
fondamentale
voi sapete
una delle grandi
spaccature dell'Europa
fra l'Europa del vino
e l'Europa della birra
ora il cibo
ha una funzione simbolica
è evidente
ho parlato del vino
finora
parliamo anche del cibo
salimbene ha fatto
questo viaggio in francia
di cui vi parlavo
e durante questo viaggio
in francia
ha avuto tante avventure
ha conosciuto tanta gente
ha incontrato più volte
il re luigi
luigi nono
il santo
che proprio allora
andava incrociata
questa è stata un'esperienza
grossa
perché salimbene
anche se uno disilluso
non si aspetta niente
dalla gente
sa che succede il peggio
però sa riconoscere
gli uomini santi
e ha un'ammirazione profonda
per chi riesce a essere santo
ecco il re luigi
era uno così
il re luigi è andato
incrociata
è partito
dalla francia del nord
per andarsi a imbarcare
a egg morti
in provenza
ha attraversato
tutto il regno
a piedi
non a cavallo
col bastone
e la bisaccia
da pellegrino
perché andare incrociata
significa innanzitutto
andare in pellegrinaggio
andare a gerusalemme
quindi il re di francia
ha passato mesi e mesi
a attraversare a piedi
il suo regno
in abito da pellegrino
fermandosi nelle città
fermandosi nei conventi
dei frati
a mangiare con loro
a discutere con loro
a parlare con loro
Salimbeni l'ha incontrato
diverse volte
durante questo suo viaggio
una volta stavano uscendo
dalla città di Sanz
incontro al re
il re arriva
e il vescovo di Sanz
gli manda un regalo
cosa si manda
in regalo a un re
questa appunto
è un'epoca semplice
è un'epoca in cui
le cose semplici
concrete
quotidiane
contano
il vescovo
in regalo al re
manda
un grande luccio
vivo
dentro una tinozza
piena d'acqua
e questo è un regalo
degno di un re
Salimbeni dice ai francesi
il luccio piace
a lui evidentemente
lui non è un mantovano
è di Parma
a lui il luccio
non piace
ma dice ai francesi
il luccio piace
stava dentro
quella roba
che si usa
per lavare i neonati
quando uno gli toglie
le fasce
deve lavarli
quella roba
che i toscani
chiamano bigoncia
perché interessa
molto anche la lingua
a Salimbeni
ha sempre delle notazioni
sugli usi delle parole
ecco
al re si regala
un luccio
ed è un regalo
degno di un re
dopodichè il re
entra nel convento
dei francescani
e parla con loro
e gli dice
che lui non è venuto
a chiedere soldi
la crociata la paga lui
è venuto a chiedere
soltanto le loro preghiere
e dice Salimbeni
tutti i frati francesi
piangevano
lui che è italiano
è un po' meno coinvolto
naturalmente
specialmente dal fatto
di non chiedere i soldi
ma comunque
tutti i francesi
piangevano
dopodichè
vanno a pranzo
col re
e il pranzo del re
io vediamo
se lo ritrovo
il pranzo del re
è questo
Salimbeni se lo ricordo ancora
molti decenni di distanza
cosa hanno mangiato
quel giorno col re
il modo di concepire
un pranzo
della gente di quell'epoca
era molto diverso
dal nostro
i gusti erano diversi
soprattutto
non c'era la nostra idea
diciamo di una gradazione
per cui si comincia
con i salati
poi si passa i dolci
no loro
mescolavano volentieri
cose diverse
questo hanno mangiato
quel giorno
era un giorno
di magro
si mangiava pesce
è stato
dice Salimbeni
un pranzo magnifico
degno di un grande re
e tuttavia
al tempo stesso
vedrete
non è stato un banchetto
da ricco e pulone
è una cosa degna
di un grande re
che però è anche
un grande santo
dice per prima cosa
quel giorno
abbiamo mangiato ciliegie
poi hanno portato
il pane bianco
bianchissimo
e il vino
poi sono venute
fave fresche
cotte nel latte
poi pesci
e gamberi
e polpette
di anguilla
poi riso
con latte
di mandorle
e polvere
di cinnamomo
poi anguille
alla braccia
con un'ottima salsa
torte salate
giuncata
frutta
un grande pranzo
però appunto
per chi faccia i confronti
con altri pranzi
di cui parla Salimbene
questo appunto
è un pranzo
che è degno
della magnificenza
di un re
ma al tempo stesso
non smentisce
l'umiltà di quest'uomo
che è un santo
e sta andando a piedi
a imbarcarsi
perché Salimbene
ne conosce ben altre
di storie di pranzi
e di menù
che non sono
altrettanto dignitose
per esempio
il modo
in cui
il patriarca
di Aquileia
celebra
la Quaresima
Salimbene
lo racconta
dice
i patriarchi di Aquileia
farebbero meglio
cambiare sistema
veramente
comunque dice
mi risulta
che fanno così
il quaresima
dura 40 giorni
deve preparare
al grande momento
della grande
tristezza
del venerdì santo
e poi alla gioia
della risurrezione
dura 40 giorni
è un cammino
di avvicinamento
quindi il patriarca
di Aquileia
la quaresima
la celebra così
sono 40 giorni
il primo giorno
fa servire
un pranzo
di 40 portate
il secondo giorno
il terzo
e in questo modo
arriva al sabato santo
con una sola portata
e si è veramente
avvicinato gradualmente
al digiuro
e alla penitenza
dice Salimbene
veramente Cristo
ha digiunato
40 giorni
e 40 notti
nel deserto
e i patriarchi di Aquileia
farebbero meglio
ricordarselo
ecco
io sono arrivato
quasi alla fine
anzi alla fine
del mio tempo
quindi chiuderò
rapidamente
ci sono tante cose
ancora di Salimbene
che andrebbero dette
qualcuna
l'ho messa addirittura
nel programma
del nostro festival
e non l'ho ancora detta
il fatto che ogni tanto
gli scappano anche
dei giudizi ingenerosi
indubbiamente
perché lui è un gran signore
che non guarda in faccia
nessuno
e le cose le dice come stanno
se deve dire male di un papa
dice male di un papa
se deve dire male di un popolo
dice male di un popolo
non gliene importa niente
nella nostra Italia di oggi
così spaccata
così attraversata
da tensioni
anche regionali
magari non fa ridere
però ormai
l'ho messo nel programma
del convegno
del festival
quindi lo diciamo lo stesso
Salimbene a un certo punto
se la prende con quelli
dell'Italia meridionale
dice quelli dell'Italia meridionale
sta raccontando
all'epoca in cui
i normanni
hanno conquistato
l'Italia del sud
dice i normanni
l'hanno conquistata facilmente
perché quelli lì
non sanno combattere
non sono capaci
non valgono niente
a quelli lì
pugliesi
siciliani
dice
ve lo dico
nel latino
di Salimbene
voi scoprirete
di sapere tutti il latino
di capirlo perfettamente
sunt homines
caccarelli
et merdazzoli
e poi fa un'altra annotazione
dice
parlano in un modo strano
quelli del sud
parlano nella gola
quando vogliono dire
che vuoi
dicono
che boli
da questo impariamo
se non altro
che già allora
gli italiani appunto
erano faziosi
e non amavano niente
quanto dir male
gli uni degli altri
io mi fermerei
piuttosto
sulla annotazione linguistica
come vi dicevo
Salimbene è molto sensibile
alla lingua
ci sta attento
nella cronaca
spesso cita frasi in francese
che ha sentito
orecchiato
e poi osserva delle cose
per esempio
l'uso dei pronomi
dice il tu
e il voi
dovrebbe essere regolamentato
si dà del tu
in certi casi
e si dà del voi
in certi altri
il lei
non esisteva ancora
nell'italiano di allora
o il tu
o il voi
e Salimbene dice
però in realtà
in Italia
non si fa mica così
ogni zona d'Italia
fa a modo suo
quelli del sud
e di Roma
danno del tu
a tutti
anche al papa
poi magari lo chiamano
messer
ma gli dicono
tu messer papa
e invece i lombardi
e dicendo i lombardi
lui intende anche
se stesso
tutti gli italiani
del nord
lombardi
nell'italiano di allora
significa tutta l'Italia
del nord
i lombardi
dice Salimbene
danno del voi
a tutti
dare del voi
a un bambino
va bene
ma i lombardi
danno del voi
anche a una gallina
a un gatto
darebbero del voi
anche a un pezzo di legno
e qui
e qui chiudo davvero
l'ultimo aspetto
della mentalità
di Salimbene
che mi pare il caso
di sottolineare
è la sua estrema curiosità
lui è attento a tutto
è attento a cogliere
le cose strane
le cose nuove
è attento a raccogliere
le notizie che arrivano
è attento a notare
le differenze
in campo alimentare
per esempio
a un certo punto
verso la fine
lui è vecchio ormai
va per i 70
a un certo punto
lui dice
certo che la golosità umana
non ha proprio limiti
diventiamo sempre più golosi
e si inventano sempre cose nuove
quest'anno alla festa
di Santa Chiara
ho mangiato
per la prima volta
ravioli
senza crosta di pasta
cosa voglia dire
questo
a me ha lasciato
molto perplesso
devo dire
inizialmente pensavo
che volesse dire
il raviolo
senza la sfoglia intorno
c'è soltanto il ripieno
del raviolo
poi mi son detto
che probabilmente
è un po' diverso
nel medioevo
cucinavano molto volentieri
le cose al forno
dentro le torte salate
di sfoglia
il pie inglese
ripieno di carne
ecco che noi consideriamo
un po' barbaro
in effetti è un piatto medievale
è rimasto tale quale
loro cucinavano volentieri così
dunque può anche darsi
che lui fosse abituato
a mangiare i ravioli
passati poi al forno
dentro una torta salata
e che lì invece
per la prima volta
gli erano portati
senza l'esterno
non lo so
chiederemo a Massimo Montanari
come giudicare questo fatto
ma il punto
che mi interessava
sottolineare
è che a lui nulla sfugge
ecco e scrive
le cose che lo colpiscono
le scrive
va in Francia
si accorge che in Francia
del nord
in certe stagioni
i giorni sono più lunghi
che in Italia
e in certe altre
sono più corti
e lo scrive
si imbarca a Genova
per andare in Provenza
si accorge che il clima
è diverso
dice sono partito da Genova
che i mandorli
erano in fiore
sono arrivato in Provenza
sui mandorli
c'erano già i frutti
grossi così
Provenza fa più caldo
evidentemente
si trova in Francia
sempre durante
il suo grande viaggio
quando era giovane
ad accogliere il re
fuori dalla città di Sainz
e dice
dalla città di Sainz
è uscita la processione
delle dame della città
ad accogliere il re
io le ho guardate
mi hanno detto
guarda le dame della città
le ho guardate
e mi sono detto
ma a me mi sembrano più
delle cameriere queste
e poi mi sono ricordato
che in Francia
i gentiluomini
i nobili
non stanno in città
stanno nei loro castelli
non è come da noi in Italia
che nelle città
vivono i nobili cavalieri
qui nelle città
ci vivono soltanto
i mercanti
gli artigiani
e si capisce
che le loro donne
fossimo stati a Parma
le dame di Parma
avrebbero fatto
tutta un'altra figura
dunque la curiosità
l'attenzione alle differenze
sempre in un clima
diciamo però
di conoscenza
di come sono gli uomini
però una conoscenza
e l'ho già detto otto volte
lo dico per la nonna
qui davvero chiudo
una conoscenza
che comunque secondo me
giudica raramente
ed è sempre attenta
a cogliere
gli aspetti umani
delle cose
e in questo
lui è molto diverso
per esempio
dall'imperatore Federico II
l'imperatore Federico II
che lui appunto
ha conosciuto
a cui ha voluto anche bene
poi pensava
che fosse lui l'anticristo
poi ha saputo
che era morto
ci è rimasto malissimo
ecco l'imperatore Federico II
era un uomo
fuori dal normale
aveva anche lui
delle curiosità
ma era delle curiosità
malsane
erano delle curiosità
di uno che non è
non è tanto umano
ne racconto solo una
che racconta salimbene
dice l'imperatore Federico II
a un certo punto
si è messo in testa
di capire
qual è la lingua primigenia
dell'umanità
perciò ha preso
dei bambini neonati
e ha dato ordine
alle nutrici
di allevarli
senza però fargli
nessuna coccole
senza parlargli mai
voleva vedere
in che lingua
avrebbero parlato
se avrebbero parlato
in greco
o in latino
o in ebraico
o in arabo
o magari
nella lingua
dei loro genitori
ma dice salimbene
ha sprecato il suo tempo
perché quei bambini
morivano tutti
e poi salimbene
dice questa cosa
che a me sembra straordinaria
per forza
morivano tutti
perché i neonati
non possono vivere
senza le coccole
e i sorrisi
e i battiti di mano
e le carezze
e le chiacchiere
delle nutrici
non possono
e questa cosa
l'imperatore Federico II
che era un genio
non era abbastanza umano
per capirla evidentemente
invece salimbene
con tutti i suoi difetti
è abbastanza umano
da capirla
e da saperla
e dunque appunto
quello che io spero
di essere riuscito a trasmettere
è che quest'uomo
che sotto tanti aspetti
era tanto diverso da noi
e che era pieno di difetti
però insomma
ecco
ci ha lasciato un'opera
dentro in cui
da cui viene fuori un uomo
insomma ecco
un uomo
tutto a 360 gradi
io ve ne ho potuti dare
soltanto degli assaggi
dei pezzetti
però
è un uomo
che quando uno legge
quelle cose
impara a conoscere
diventa uno che conosci
e io spero
insomma un pochino
di avere trasmesso
qualche cosa di questo
stasera
grazie
grazie a tutti